these volunteers are about to learn a
lot about the benefits of fresh air
lease delano is the activist behind the
tree planting campaign the meeting place
is no coincidence it's the epicenter of
exhaust emissions in this city of nearly
5 million resolve them all remember
you're amazed that many more people came
to participate in the reforestation
campaign than we expected at the fastest
you can use it really on
banco forest is just outside the Ivorian
commercial capital abidjan it's clearly
visible from the highway but many urban
residents have never been here before
please studied environmental management
in abidjan then founded his own
organization with this campaign he wants
a bichon residents to understand that
banco forest is the city's source of
oxygen sittin gon meet football yeah
this is a large metropolis there are so
many cars the ones you see here in the
city are usually bad for the environment
there 10 15 or even 20 years old
sometimes even older than that with that
Bunko forest the Aaron abidjan would
probably be much worse recent studies
show that people already breathe in
3,000 tons of carbon dioxide here every
day with its abundant vegetation and
rare tree species the forest exudes a
kind of magic part of it remains
untouched and has been designated a
national park but many trees are being
cut down outside the protected area in
2009 this entire space was a rainforest
today it's full of residential buildings
and factories there's only one thing to
do to save part of the cleared area
plant more trees participants plant
various kinds of trees including mccrory
younger and teamo it was Casey a wounded
simple his volunteers say the air is
clean and refreshing and healthy the
funds for this campaign come from an
annual environmental conference more
than 70 new trees have been planted just
today to assess the impact of his
efforts briefs returns to the rain
forest facet ridiculous looking at this
natural beauty I would like every
Ivorian to get involved and preserve it
and stop cutting down trees
what is out they should be protected as
the same goes for the whole environment
everyone should come to this space so
they can learn how to love nature home
Emile I'm not you lease Delano has been
able to inspire more than 130 volunteers
with his initiative he's also taken his
campaign to neighboring Burkina Faso and
Ghana